i think an accent is not a stereotype
you know an accent is just how you talk
and there are asians who sound like me i
grew up sounding more like uncle roger
than how i sound now
and there are people who act like uncle
roger you know sit in the asian coffee
teams coffee shops and they are in their
tank tops smoking with their ears on the
side talking [__] about everything they
have good knees where they just squat
like it's nothing yeah yeah oh yeah when
you sit on the leg on the chair you know
most people can't do it but it's
comfortable your knees are so good
in five four three
two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
have a very very special guest today
nigel [__] ing yes let me tell
you something man you are the now most
beloved asian on youtube
there is not a single [__] asian
person that loves you more than anybody
on youtube like you are literally the
the top
really when we walked in this dude
freaked the [__] out when he saw you
yeah yeah yeah it's it's crazy milton
right there yeah guy i was i would say
that there are people who hate me
there's always you do youtube stuff you
know there are a lot of people who like
it but they're also you know like you
said sensitive people who'd be like how
can you exploit the accent bro and it's
like well what grew up talking like that
man well that's the that's the weird
thing too right like um
so what's like the biggest amount of
hate that you get
biggest amount of hate well
i would say last year
uh i was caught in this like controversy
china stuff political stuff that was the
biggest thing i actually i i mean my
friend mentioned it on the podcast a
little bit but maybe you could elaborate
on it but i heard it was like some
[__] dude it is some [__] i
became i just caught got caught in this
crossfire you know how western countries
they
a lot of western countries they don't
like china they treat china with like
this kind of like
you know fear slash disrespect
and then we don't have to get too much
into this but every time china [__] up
it gets reported but when china does
something good it never gets reported in
mainstream western media yeah yeah yeah
but basically i i i did a collab with a
youtuber who i thought just a food
vlogger but turns out he's uh one very
very vocally anti-china on social media
and also he's part of uh
a organization that's considered it's
called falun gong they do the shannon
stuff you know i have no judgment on any
of this is it is he's more vocal about
uh against like the ccp yeah against ccp
but his involvement in that group is
also uh in china it's considered a very
big uh you know sin you know you don't
do that yeah yeah yeah and also because
i have chinese social media platforms i
speak mandarin i have a family out in
china so i like you know connecting with
the chinese fans i'm a way board billy
billy doing are you familiar with the
chinese stuff uh somewhat yeah yeah yeah
a little bit like that so when the video
went up
my chinese social media account started
getting reported by like the people that
because oh look at this nigel is
collaborating with this known cultist
what happened man yeah yeah yeah so
i was you said i was [__] either way
if i kept the video up my chinese
accounts get nuked if i take the video
down i know the western people will be
like oh he's kowtowing to the ccp yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i decided to um uh
take the video down which was
terrible idea and the western world just
started coming at me so that was the
biggest biggest hit except five seconds
man it's like a lose-lose situation it's
a loose yeah yeah yeah but that's so
weird though i mean just because you
were interviewing somebody else suddenly
like you have an alliance with like that
it wasn't even an interview it was we're
just talking about dumplings man just
reviewing like shitty dumplings
dumplings [__] what are you talking
about yeah and i was new to this whole
like and i just started getting a little
bit of success you know so
my chinese i have a chinese social media
team who manages the videos they
subtitle them and then they post it for
me oh that's [__] so they come at it
from a chinese angle okay okay when
people like like you know john cena and
then [__] up this is what they do you
know so
i was idiot i was like blindly following
their advice without knowing how it
looks from the western world yeah
because there really is no pr company as
of now who's
versed in both the western and the asian
world you know it's two different
companies working together and it's just
i mean i'll tell you this
[__] all that [__] dude because at the
end of the day man
here's the greatest example people
look at logan paul logan paul [__]
recorded somebody committing suicide in
a [__] forest and people don't
remember that anymore yeah i remember i
actually went in to seek out that video
i was interested in that kind of [__]
and i just think it's just
how he angled it you know because if he
went with a little bit of respect and
sort of like what's up guys you know
what's up logan today we're gonna see
people killing themselves man you know
you know what i buy my merch yeah it's
so different right i think like what
his situation was very unique just
because and i'll say this now as
somebody who kind of reflects back on it
he is at him he's still super young now
yeah right but even then he was like i
think he was maybe 20 maybe even younger
has the whole world around him has a
whole bunch of yes men around him
everything he does is gold so there's
not there's nobody in his team that's
going to be like hey bro that's super
disrespectful they're like wait how his
mind works as a young person is i know
this is going to get millions of views
let's just [__] do it yeah yeah so he
got a little thumbnail in his head
already exactly
so the thumbnail was hurting there and
then he's like all right dead body let's
go yeah so because in all the standards
it is a good youtube video you talk
about this idea or what bro what if we
go visit a suicide forest yeah they'll
get clicks you know it is a good youtube
idea there's execution maybe you know
he's also a young guy and people i think
people are too hard on these public
figures
he was the reason why adpocalypse
started
really it was from that video it's like
it was from there
yes he did that's why i [__] hate his
guts bro i was rich
so if you guys don't know after that
video what happened was um
advertisements on youtube they weren't
really scrutinized right it was just
whatever video was up you could put
whatever ads yeah which to me made sense
but a lot of these companies like for
example it would be like huggies pampers
they're like hold on a second i don't
want my diapers to be associated with
this suicide video yeah and so a lot
it's like google had to do this whole
reinvention of how ads are placed which
is why it's a lot more complicated now
before it was just you sign up once you
hit an x amount of views whatever ads go
on so these cpms were really [__]
high so on average so for example if you
look at like uh children's channels
right their cpms can be up to like 10 to
20 dollars
my cpms are like a dollar yeah right
ryan's toy reviews he's rolling in it
yeah yeah [__] that kid all right that
[__] rich ass little kid dude but
that was the start of adpocalypse and
that's when it changed the game for
everybody you know with that channel
people always say like uh i they think
his parents are ripping him off i'm like
well wouldn't you if your kid's like
making like hundreds of millions a year
wouldn't you kind of abuse him a little
bit is he filipino
yeah i think so i feel like an american
maybe yeah well he's asian then yeah of
course his parents can rip him off
most kids work for free anyway
i mean like what's the idea behind that
too because it's like i'm pretty sure
that when he hits 18 he's gonna
rack in all this [__] i'll say this i'm
pretty sure he doesn't get beat as a kid
and that is if you're pulling in
hundreds of millions for your parents he
does one video yeah he goes
ryan got beat today and he has like this
wonderful black eye
destroys his whole parents dreams i bet
you he controlled his parents
yes you know i could just sock myself in
the eye today
that's so [__] funny dude
like
so let me just go back right just
because i don't know if um
anybody knows like too many personal
stuff about you so where are you from
where did you grow up i'm from malaysia
kuala lumpur kl as we call it never been
to malaysia but i know that malaysia and
indonesia has some of the best graphic
design artists ever the cheapest
the cheapest the most like diligent
they're just so good all my graphic
designs are all from people from
malaysia indonesia dude yeah i i work
with both like teams in asia and teams
in the west and
the number of auto responder emails i
get from british workers
every time holiday rolls around oh sorry
it's not my problem please contact this
guy i'm out till january 16th yeah yeah
yeah my god and in asia i've never had
an autoresponder response oh it's always
them yeah it's always them and it's over
a group chat we use whatsapp right it's
like a group chat essentially and i
would text them because of the time
difference
when they get the email it's 10 p.m
their time i'll be in the texas tempe
and their time and they still respond
yeah you know that's always super
[__] good so like every graphic that
i've done now if if i go on something
like i don't know like fiverr i go are
they from indonesia or are they from
malaysia if not i don't want anything to
do with them well thank you thank you
it's very very proud of my people how
long were you there before you moved to
to london i grew up there for the first
20 years of my life and then i moved to
the u.s i went to northwestern from
university so i lived in chicago you
know evanston illinois and then chicago
five years total
what the [__] you were you were here so
i know about trader joe's
that's what i mean
every time i come back to the us man
it's lacroix and bacon that's that's
what i miss bacon yeah american bacon
you've put so much chemicals in it that
is so delicious
it's crispy and it's full of sulfites
and apparently it's bad but like you
know life is too short to eat healthy
all the time i i have a bunch of friends
who uh went to like uh the uk for you
know like study abroad programs and
people always [__] on the food british
yeah it's terrible have you been there i
haven't been there but what the [__] is
it why why is it so bad like it's bland
you know it's like europe without the
good food you know you know you go to
europe you like spain amazing food
france amazing food britain
it's getting better now london i'll say
london is getting better but anyway
outside of london man yeah a buddy of
mine was christian and he was telling me
that because i was asking him i was like
how's the food there he goes dude the
only thing i ate was indian food
fish and chips and beer that's it i'm
surprised you even try fish and chips
that's the most boring
i feel like the food in that area just
it hasn't really like evolved or caught
up they kind of just like what they like
yeah from what from what people have
told me so like i was watching this
video years ago it was some guy who
makes like like it was like the first
fast food ever and it was something
called jellied eel oh god yeah i've had
that before so you had it what the [__]
does that taste like
it's slimy it's like it's like if you
really [__] up sushi you know you have
eel in sushi yeah yeah right it's
delicious and they and they have like a
little bit of teriyaki sauce on it and
that jelly is cold
and then they have this kind of slimy
gelatinous thing on the outside
and i don't know who eats it but and
it's vinegary or british food they love
pudding vinegar and stuff
and it's like
vinegar sucks
stop putting tabasco on [__] you know
tabasco used sriracha you know every
time i
like just just this morning i had an
omelet i asked for sriracha and they
gave me tabasco i'm like
this is worse the worst version
you know where did you where did you go
eat i just at my hotel uh i'm staying at
a soho warehouse down i'm gonna take
this [__] out eat some tacos yes
yes i was craving mexican food man
mexican food in london you can't get
mexican even in the states yeah the
mexicans haven't gotten there yet yeah
outside of california is just a little a
little it's not sus it's just like
i don't know what the [__] it is like
you gotta go to california and get good
mexican food and even if or mexico you
know
mexican people in mexico don't know what
they're talking about
but the crate the crazy thing is like
even in california outside of los
angeles or san diego or anywhere close
to the border where you know the source
is where mexico is
it's still it's not that good no no i
agree i agree that's why i was i was
craving it you know so i'm excited for
that oh dude i'm like the taco king out
here bro yeah bring me around man so so
years ago um i started uh i started
doing food right just because i like
food and at the time i was like 300
pounds so that's all i did
all i did was [__] eat and um i
started posting up about these these uh
taco spots in east l.a east l.a a lot of
people who aren't mexican just don't go
there right at the time okay and this
was about like seven or eight years ago
so i started posting up like these spots
and then slowly these stars started
blowing up so there was a spot
originally called avenue 26 and a lot of
people go there now but
shout out to the homie caesar uh did a
video for them and they [__] blew the
[__] up like it was literally over like
a month and then all of a sudden the
place was packed the [__] out and so
slowly like words started getting around
like yo this [__] asian guy is like
yeah blowing our spots up
and so i i did another video for on
another spot it's called uh iberia la
unica out in east l.a and they do like
media which is like a stewed goat or
beef
that spot too he told me like before i
did a video for them
he only saw like mexican people go there
and he said after your video asian
people white people mexican people
everybody was going to that spot which
blew my mind yeah what kind of video was
this like a vlog thing you just went
there what's up guys we're gonna have
some tacos today so what i would do is i
would hit these spots and i would call
them as like hey i i want to do a food
video for you guys because i've been
eating you for a while i just want to
you know show you guys some love and
they would let me go into the truck and
shoot everything and then i would just
review the food joke around [__] around
like this but then have food with it uh
and so it just became a thing where i
was just hitting up all these different
taco spots but those guys which the cool
thing about that little taco community
is it's seemingly they support each
other so they would tell their other
friends who have different businesses
about me and they would ask me to come
nice nice sometimes the food wasn't good
i wouldn't do a video for them because i
didn't want to [__] on them you know i
mean well you should it's it's funny
like i mean i do that for a
and then all of a sudden
they're just like out of business their
kids are starving and i'm like i know
you [__] on them it it also helps
business too really yeah yeah i i've
done a video where you know i reviewed
jamie oliver and he [__] up egg fried
rice by putting chili jam in it right so
i did a video where i visit a chili jam
factory and i just kind of [__] on the
ceo and [__] on the jam
and people actually like it and you know
in the end i was like yeah it tastes
fine whatever yeah but people it still
helps bring the awareness for you
you get to play this character yeah the
character is the person that gets to do
that because i'm just me that is true so
now i don't think you're a dick yes
no i'm just a [__] dick
bonjour
this podcast is brought to you by
adam and eve my friends
okay that's enough of that
my friends
if you haven't heard of adam and eve and
you're looking to spice up your
valentine's day guess what head on over
to adam and eve
dot
com my friends because if you're
planning to spice things up in the
bedroom this valentine's season you
better go ahead and check them out when
you go to adamandeve.com you can select
almost any one item and you'll get it at
50 percent off don't be shy my friends
my friends uh le kim le pepe le pew is
telling you that you know it's about
time you spice it up no we
time for you okay but listen that's not
all when you select your one item you
will also get free shipping so head on
over to adamandeve.com and be sure to
use offer code genius again that's
g-e-n-i-u-s
genius that's genius adam and eve dot
com and my friends have a happy
valentine's day there was a kid so we
did we had this other show with my
friend tim uh it's called sen foods and
we did it at this filipino festival and
i guess like one of the kids messaged us
because so i ate one of these cookies
right and i still stand by till the day
the driest cookie i've ever had in my
life i put it in my mouth and i just let
it fall out of my mouth i was like yikes
this [__] sucks
but i didn't mention the name of the
business because i didn't want to do all
that stuff but this little message just
saying like you [__] ruined my
family's business
we went out like our business went out i
was like first of all number one i
didn't take your family out of business
the dry ass cookie did yeah all right
your [__] skills like what happened was
people somebody probably ate it they
choked and they died but
i did give them props because there were
some other cookies that i liked but you
know people just tend to get really
sensitive i mean listen i'm a food owner
too so that's why i go out of my way not
to
bash businesses because years ago when i
you know yelp do yelp elite people they
think they have like the power
yep that's the restaurant review site
right so you guys don't have the app
over there we just use google okay yeah
yeah so we have yelp and they have
something called yelp elites okay what's
that so basically it's like
you
consistently review and rate places and
they give you a badge so the people in
no life
get to decide the face of restaurants
it's exactly what happens it's people's
and a lot of the time it's not everybody
right but there's people who have never
cooked a day in their life yeah and they
go you know what this isn't authentic
it's like first of all
you are white and you went into a thai
restaurant what the [__] do you know
about authenticity yeah you know and
they they just bash this business like
for me too the only time i'll leave like
a one star review is if like the person
like
that you had to do something pretty
[__] heinous
spit in my food you know call me a [__]
and just [__] you know spread your
eyes like this that's that's a lot to go
it's hard to get one star with you it's
really hard
and then but if they did all that but if
they did all that and the food's good
how many stars
easy i was like listen i was called a
[__] and i had the best tom yum i've
ever had in my life
so that's how you know listeners if you
want to like test how good your food is
yes
call david a [__] and i serve him your
food see how many stars you get it's
like you [__] goo get the hell out of
here and i eat the food i'm like hey
five stars you call me whatever the [__]
you want but that's like asian service
though at restaurants i agree like i
would i would rather if i could choose
please racially abuse me but make the
food edible
you know some places they treat you
western restaurants man treat you so
nice and it's a blandest food can i help
you today well yeah improve your food
jesus dude i i always say this too so i
mentioned this one vietnamese
bun me spot it's a vietnamese sandwich
yeah
this lady every time i go there she's so
[__] mean to me but the sandwiches
are so good i go every [__] week and
every time i try to say something nice
to her and she basically tells me to go
die went there yesterday right came in
thought she was in a good mood she was
saying hi i was like good morning i was
like you look really pretty today she
goes she goes hurry up what do you want
same man there's a dim sum place in
london i love going uh joy king lao if
you're there and then they know me they
know who uncle roger is and they're
still dicks to me
they just come up to me oh love your
videos man okay by the way you can you
only get one shot at ordering because
the steamer takes too long and they just
want to get you out as quick as possible
right and that's that's the treatment
and i speak cantonese to them trying to
be nice to them and i still get treated
like [__] so i can only imagine a white
person
how much abuse they would get that's the
only place where white privilege doesn't
work
restaurants they don't give a [__] dude
they'll put their thumb right in the
soup
they'll serve it out to you and you
complain like what what that's what we
do if you if you [__] yourself you're a
[__]
you're too weak dude i'll read reviews
on uh like these asian restaurants right
and they'll have like three stars but
every asian person knows that this is
the spot you go to the great get great
food yeah but it's always like some kind
of it's like an americanized asian
person who has just
has denounced their asian style oh yeah
you have a lot of those here yeah we
have a lot of those here yeah uh it's
it's weird man like i think recently
because of whether it's social media or
people talking about stuff now now
they're trying to come back and claim
their asianness it's cool again yeah
it's it's like a cool thing to do but i
remember there was like a lot of asian
kids in america that they would just not
want to be associated with being asian
which is weird because i wasn't born i
was born in korea and
so my first language was korean and i
was always super proud of to be korean
you know what i mean i always wanted to
learn the language i loved the music i
loved everything what's the percentage
of asians in your high school
there was a lot that was a lot okay i
think that's that's the thing if you go
into if you're the only asian kid i
think it's a little bit easier to hate
yourself for sure i mean it's hard like
i i didn't realize that um early on um i
only realized that after i started
traveling because i i always say this
too i grew up in a very blessed
neighborhood in the sense i mean it was
kind of hood and ghetto but it was
diverse so we would have like
every quarter or semester they would
have a culture a culture festival where
everybody gets to bring their own food
and share it with people a lot of people
in high school outside of where i live
didn't have that yeah they were like six
or seven asian kids and
i kind of felt really bad for them when
i would hear their stories where they
would make asian jokes and if they
didn't laugh they were like oh you have
a bad sense of humor but they would
literally make dog-eating jokes at them
yeah
we've heard it before you know what i
mean like and yeah just because you
don't laugh doesn't mean we you know you
joke [__] sometimes
it's just not funny yeah so you know i
started to understand like a lot of
different perspectives outside of my own
because i used to just you know as you
get older you get a little more mature
and i think traveling was a good idea
for me because now i got to see how
everybody else lives yeah because when a
lot of people are talking about like oh
you know people are still racist towards
asian people i didn't grow up with that
because you know majority asian area it
was majority asian black and hispanic
so what we experienced wasn't that it
was like everybody was that the white
people got bullied yeah yeah everybody
should everybody should get bullied as a
child that's how you develop a
personality right yeah i mean you know
and people are trying to avoid the
bullying thing and it's just not
possible it's just a part of like the
human nature you go on tick tock and
then you just post a tick tock if you're
a little bit bigger
i got banned from [__] tick tock
really
what'd you say this time i just said
[__] you say [__] and then you attack
charlie
[__] you charlie you
talentless [__]
i just i always just have to talk [__]
you know what the thing is too like you
know it's that's how i i i've always
known about you yeah and i was i was a
fan i liked your podcast and stuff and
then one day you tagged me in a tweet
like who the [__] is this peter charles
want to be that's that's how i got to
know the funny david knows me okay great
you know what the funny thing is is like
everybody kept tagging me right and
they're like yo this guy's biting off
peter chow peter chow it's like cool and
i looked at it and i was like okay i
tweeted that real quick and then when i
saw your videos like this is funny
i saw your stand up i saw your other
stuff i was like
why are people making a big ass deal out
of nothing you know because yeah and
that's why i said on my podcast i'm like
there's more things to nigel than this
one little thing and so for my thing was
like i saw it i was like yeah it's not
it's like it didn't make me laugh
because it's like stuff that i've
probably already seen yeah but
i think the the thing that made me
switch it was like
people have there's like two sides to
this right people have an issue with
asian people using the accents but it's
still a part of us yeah why can't we use
something that is a part of who we are
yeah so when i started watching your
videos
i was like okay i saw one video and i
saw it again and i was like
it's it's a lot more nuanced tonight
than i thought it was right
but i don't think so but i think this is
what i mean by it though it's like you
grew up in [__] malaysia
it's way more authentic than you grew up
in [__] here
you know what i mean so it's like kind
of like in my perspective it was like
well what the [__] am i talking about
then it doesn't really make sense to me
in that sense for me to kind of go you
know there's a lot of like weird
introspective thoughts that i had to
myself where before when i would look at
something that i didn't like i would
just be like i would just write it off
but then all i had to do was look at you
once and then see all your other stuff
and i'm like oh this shit's [__]
hilarious yeah i grew up in malaysia man
i shut in a [__] in a hole okay that's
the most asian you can get your asian
squad when you take a [__] you know yeah
so i got to do the accent because if you
[__] in the hole you got to do the
accent
but you know i always say this to people
because this has come up before in
different interviews i think an accent
is not a stereotype you know an accent
is just how you talk and there are
asians who sound like me i grew up
sounding more like uncle roger than how
i sound now
and uh there are people who act like
uncle roger you know sit in the asian
coffee times coffee shops and they are
in a tank top smoking with beers on the
side talking [__] about everything those
are good knees where they just squat
like it's nothing yeah yeah oh yeah when
you sit on the leg on the chair you know
most people can't do it but it's
uncomfortable your knees are so good
and i would say too
going back to the topic of like growing
up uh how you grow up i feel very
privileged to grow up in asia very lucky
because you know i was the default
you know so you grow up with a healthy
sense of self
and uh i make fun of the especially like
people who are half white half asian and
they grow up in the west you know
british born chinese people who are half
chinese half british and i tell them
like your mom wanted that white dick too
much and now now you're [__] and you
need to go to therapy because your mom
likes the white dick you know mama just
did my mom dated like a nice malaysian
you know man yeah yeah it was good we
had good representation we grew up
because i speak uh you know a bit of
cantonese mandarin a lot so we grew up
watching like the hong kong the tvb
shows so
representation was always good we saw
people who look like us yeah
on tv so coming here uh yeah you have
different problems but i have to say too
i feel like it's improving a little bit
yeah in these few years like you know
and i think too it's like
when i look back at um
i've never really cared about
representation to be honest with you
like it's never been something that's in
my mind tim tim dylan one of my favorite
uh podcasters he had a line and like he
said like is representation always good
you know representation is not always
good because um friends you know you
look at the show friends
all white people are represented on
there and that's why you feel like it's
okay to have roommates when you're 35.
yeah so i was like good point
representation is not always good and
also sometimes just because the race is
the same when i watch singles inferno i
don't feel represented i'm not chiseled
and six two with a beautiful face you
know so well that's the thing too like
it's so hard for people to even hear
that sometimes and you know i think like
yeah we get heated about racial topics
and stuff right but that's fine it's in
the moment when people always tell me
like oh what do you think about doesn't
it feel good that you get to see more of
your face on tv it's never affected my
outlook on life though so you're asking
the wrong person here you know yeah when
i looked at superman i never said well i
can't be like superman as a kid this
[__] kryptonian like
i never looked at it like that it was
just oh this is a guy with crazy
superpowers and and sometimes we don't
need okay this might i might you might
get a bit of flack for this but
sometimes you don't need representation
you know i grew up you know when i
watched star wars to me it's like some
wacky white people sci-fi [__] and
samuel jackson
but then like the latest star wars they
they're asian they're the what uh rose
right rosemary tran well you're an asian
actress in it and japanese girls yeah
very very good vietnamese girl but then
that brings a lot of questions i'm like
okay so where were the asians from star
wars one to six they killed them all
yeah were they locked up somewhere
because we went to like seven different
planets and
like two black people and there are
other wacky asians uh wacky white people
in long hair you know yeah and like
and not for it to be misconstrued i
think it's dope i think like that's the
conversation like it's cool to see but i
hate it when people tell me to make a
big deal out of something that i don't
want to yeah you know it's like i
appreciate it i like it but
for me for you expect me to wave this
huge flag of like yeah it's about time
there's a [__] chinese person i can
start like i'm like hey that's really
cool and it could just be like that but
you know social media has kind of like
pulled us to be like you have to be here
or you have to get here yeah you can't
just be in the middle and say i like
that that's good that's okay that's
pretty cool yeah and it's like
completely fine too like
i wanted to so when when did you start
popping off was it like the last three
years july 2020
so it's reset recent yeah yeah i was i
was doing a bit of youtube at the time
but mostly my stand-up or
just reaction videos or just me talking
to the camera type thing so i knew i had
the skills i was editing everything by
myself right so i had the chops how to
make a thumbnail how to edit it well so
uncle roger kind of came along and then
um it just was like you know everything
came together i had the character i had
the youtube chops i had the comedic
chops and they just blew up from there
when i first i posted a video the bbc
food egg fried rice one that was the
very first encourager youtube video
right i posted it after a week it got
ten thousand views i said yes that's a
lot it's good yeah and i crossed 10k
subs i was like yay great that's my goal
for the year and then a month later i'm
at 100k and then a million
it's crazy your trajectory was [__]
insane dude it went it was literally
that it was overnight yeah it was crazy
how much that character kind of like
opened doors how much has your life
changed since a lot yeah i've been a lot
busier now you know which is good and
very thankful because you know when when
the pandemic started you i lost all my
stand-up work you know and i've been
doing stand-up since 2011 so 10 years
damn yeah yeah yeah so you know when
people say what's up that's why i saw
your stand up like this that's [__]
hella funny you there's uh you watch
stand-up you can tell because i do stand
up you see a new act a newer act even if
their jokes are good there's still
little body language cues that
show that they're only five years in you
know what i mean so uh it did blew up
blow up overnight but it's ten years in
the making you know yeah so people don't
see the the the hustling i did yeah so
when i was married i had to ruin it
it's real it's real by the way the
marriage had to ruin to get that uncle
rogers yeah yeah
i definitely when i went back and i saw
your standup i was like oh this guy is
good and what i mean by good is exactly
what you're talking about like things
man when certain people do stand up and
they're very new at it they're very
uncomfortable and you could sense it yes
right yes and um you can see it in their
body language their mannerisms how they
how they tend to like how they hold the
mic yes how they work the mic chord when
they walk you know little things like
that and by the way quick plug i'm
coming performing instead i'm in la
april 30th and may 1st get your tickets
hell yeah baby we'll plug all that [__]
in this podcast is brought to you by
hello fresh my friends if you don't know
what hellofresh is hello fresh is where
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep it's
super easy it's freaking affordable
which is very very important and the
meals that you can create here taste so
damn good listen hello fresh is 72
percent cheaper than a restaurant meal
of the same quality and you can save on
an average of over 65 dollars per month
when you order hellofresh instead of
grocery shopping on top of that it's
easier than grocery shopping because
you're not spending and wasting time
going through aisles and aisles looking
for ingredients ingredients by the way
that most likely after you cook that
recipe you know you're going to leave
that extra stuff in the fridge and throw
it away as it goes to waste the great
thing about hellofresh is you get to try
these news recipes that are tried and
true they're super delicious and guess
what
all the portions are pre-portioned so
you have no waste and on top of that
like i just said you're going to save
money while eating delicious food it's
super easy it's super fun and by the way
everything that i made from hellofresh
has been fire i ate it all up everybody
that i served the food loved it too dude
the creamy chicken with the sun-dried
tomato the pasta it was a seasonal dish
was one of my favorite things i've ever
made and they would have never known it
was pre-portioned and ready to go let's
get it baby so go to hellofresh.com
geniusbrain16 and use codegeniusbrain16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts once a once once a man go to
hellofresh.com geniusbrain16 and use
code geniusbrain16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free
gifts that's hellofresh america's number
one meal kit
when when i saw it like how you were
doing it as oh this guy's a veteran
comic and that's when i went back i'm
like oh this is just that one little
aspect to what you did and also too if
it blows up and it's working why not
continue it yeah yeah and
uncle roger is who i'll eventually
become
if i if i didn't leave malaysia in 20
years time i would be that guy i'm just
doing my future dude what are you
talking about i'll eventually become him
in 20 years and then that's just me i'll
change my name well it was a really cool
thing it's like when uh when you hit me
up on on the dm right i was like oh cool
and then i remember you mentioned it was
like yeah i heard you didn't like uncle
roger a lot but you said a lot of other
nice things and it was so dope that you
came on this podcast because a lot of
people are actually afraid to come on
here
because you know i like to talk you talk
[__] about them you're very aggressive
you know well for me too it's like
the way i view things is it's not even
talking [__] it's like this is just a
casual conversation and so when we have
topics or something i'm not trying to be
the most knowledgeable about things i
have no willingness to
to really pull punches it's just random
thoughts right
and i say this from somebody who
probably dude there are reddits about me
where people wish for me to die really
they want me to [__] die i'm a bit
jealous now
come on uncle roger subreddit
so for me if if if i could take that
type of heat and we're just having
conversations then it's okay like like
like for example um there are a lot of
people who are you know asian american
actors or just people in the
entertainment space where there's
certain [__] that they do that i [__]
hate but then the other 80 percent i
enjoy but i'm gonna say my opinions
about the stuff i like and also the
things that i don't like yeah but as a
person doesn't mean i dislike you i'm
just talking about the content you're
creating it's not a reflection i don't
know you as a human being yeah we're
just talking about this one little
aspect so for me on the podcast it was
yeah i'm not a big fan of the the uncle
roger thing but i like all this other
stuff though so this is what makes me a
fan we get to pick and choose what we
like about somebody and so when you all
say hey you want to come on the podcast
you said yes i was like damn you're like
the first person that said yes yeah
really yeah they're just usually like
you've had guests before no but those
are the ones that are willing to come
out because they uh they tend to ghost
me a lot so they'll they'll say like hey
i really appreciate your stuff like you
have a lot of harsh criticisms cool come
on the podcast ghost
wow it's happened probably 30 or 40
times already
and it's weird because we'll have a lot
of dialogue but the moment i say you
want to come on the podcast
ghost maybe to them because i also have
my own podcast so i get the the medium
and and for a podcast because you're
talking for an hour there's no place to
hide people are gonna know the real you
and maybe especially for actors they're
worried of of how they come across how
they're perceived in the industry maybe
that's why but i'm a comic i say what's
on my mind on the podcast and encourage
your videos i'm so mean
british
cultural british legends you know jamie
oliver and angela lawson you know sorry
about that but that's why in britain
they also they probably won't put me on
like a cooking show because they think
like this guy's too mean and you know
the british sensibility they're very
reserved even if they don't like you
they don't tell you you know but i i
tell them yeah you know the orange polo
and yeah i i so you know you talk [__] i
talk [__] too so i think it's it's a
good this podcast is a good fit
well you know and i think too it's just
it's kind of nice to be in a space where
you can joke around about anything yeah
you know and that was the hard part
where there was a really long period of
time on youtube where you couldn't joke
about [__] it was really it was like
it's starting to go back now and i think
it's because a lot of comics are
fighting back they're getting a little
sick and tired of people saying like hey
you can joke about this but you can't
joke about that i want to feel special i
can make fun of you but you can't make
fun of me when was this era and what
kind of things you couldn't it's like
three or four years ago just like the
whole woke thing
and i've said this before too with if
the pendulum swings this hard here we'll
guess what's going to happen is this
swing right back yeah yeah now there are
so many podcasts that
you know they're very very funny very
unwoke but huge patreons you know huge
youtube following so yeah maybe swinging
back a little bit yeah and also too like
even with content that i [__] hate i
also i still appreciate that they're out
there doing their thing yeah if i don't
like it it's not the end of the [__]
world it's just not for me yeah there's
a lot of people too scrolls just [__]
wrong i don't understand why that's so
hard for people just enjoy what you like
and what you don't like just [__]
move on from it dude and that's okay
like i said if you could talk [__] about
me i could talk [__] about you and i
could still like you dude yeah yeah yeah
yeah i could still [__] i'm gonna
start talking [__] about you then yeah
go back go back to london and do my list
yeah
they tell other people fat [__] yeah he
thinks he's he's all that because he
owns seven matcha shops you know
let me tell you i literally told nigel
this before don't make me rich i'm
coming for everybody
it's game [__] over dude i'm
literally i i think too and look i'm
probably one of the most hated asian
people in like asian entertainment
really like once again i i
i think like it's hard for
i have no aspirations to be famous
so it's just
i could say whatever like i'm not going
to snitch on anybody i'm not going to
dry snitch or like tell people's
personal business but i'm definitely not
going to suck up the people that i just
don't really vibe with yeah and i've
i've definitely had to had like some
weird conversations at social mixers
where i'm just like hey man
get away from me
because like you know and it's better
for me that way because i don't want to
be dishonest with somebody right and i'm
not saying in the sense of like i'm
coming up to him tell me the [__] off
but if they do something that's
offensive to me i'll be like hey bro cut
that out yeah stop that [__] like i had
uh i won't say who this person is but
this person was [__] drunk
and he was coming up to me and just like
literally like an inch away from my ear
just breathing on me and you know it's
rona
yeah oh corona times yeah yeah and i'm
just like hey man can you give me some
space a little bit right he was like oh
man it's like oh i thought you were mr
tough guy or whatever what not and i was
like all right cool
step away from me i'ma sock you in your
[__] face and then he just got he
goes oh [__] i was just joking i was
like no no no you were you're you're
being a little sarcastic and you're
trying to start [__] i'll slap the
[__] [__] out you get the [__] away
from me right and the guy was like oh
[__] my bad and he kind of walked away
and that word went around fighting in
public is uh like a
rapidly dying art form
you know i miss seeing people do that
you know it's
most parties you go to is kind of most
parties could be living up a little bit
with a bit of a fight yeah right most
parties are boring as [__] man adult
parties dinner parties
oh man have you done a lot of those
because you're married right do you do a
lot of this i we so my wife and i have a
uh a very specific uh deal it's um
i only invite her to the stuff that i
know that she'll enjoy and the other way
around so we don't go to half of each
other's weddings
it it has you show up alone yeah i show
up alone well because like i still have
friends who uh i didn't grow up in a
very like nice neighborhood and so these
people grew up but we still have our
ratchet friends it's your enemies your
wife like ratchet are very classical
she's she's very classy okay you know so
white asian she's uh she's korean too
korean okay but she's she know she was a
church girl and everything else so she's
very demure uh i brought her around a
couple of my friends from back in the
day and she was mortified she was like
she's just like
who are you like who are these people
i'm like these are my friends from back
home
and she goes i never ever want to hang
out with these people ever again wow
which is understandable because how i
used to be when i was younger is
different from who i am now but when you
kick it with your old friends a lot of
that old stuff pops out yeah so now i
now we have this deal where it's kind of
code switch a bit you know yeah yeah you
have to co-switch super hard i go back
home and i and i forget how normal
people are outside of la oh yeah yeah i
think it's definitely a bubble here and
uh i talked about code switching before
and
for me i had to do it to get laid you
know university come in with an eight
you sound like uncle roger who's gonna
like suck your dick yeah you know you
peop some people coaches should get late
and not a lot of people talk about this
you know we sometimes you code switch to
sound better at job interviews but i
think you know a lot of people coming
from india going to the uk good luck man
yeah you have a strong internet with the
head tilts i got a friend with a head
tilt
and then he did significantly better
with women after he dropped the head
tilt seriously you can see his
trajectory
once a year she was uh at the time my
exes uh college course mate so first i
met him he stood at the head until he
was talking about how like dating is
hard and a year later he was dressed
nicer no more hit tilt lighter accident
i was just talking about yeah i was
[__] this chick the other day i was
seeing this other girl all i had to do
was just [__] do this fix your neck
get a stiff neck
don't do the head tilt and there's a big
correlation there you know your code
switch to to get laid you know i'll say
this too man like
maybe it's just because i don't get
offended by too many things but when
people
have the argument of like oh you know
i will say the asian and indian accent
is just funny it is it's just [__]
funny man any accent adds color yeah
conversation you know i think accents
non-white non-default accents are funny
you know italian accents uh a swedish
accent can be hilarious too you know so
actions are funny man yeah and also two
men i think it's like the accent with
the cult like i definitely see a lot of
content creators who
who kind of just use the accent as the
accent is the bit right yeah the bit
should be the joke and the accent is
just a part of it you know and that's
the part where i'm just like i can't
look at this [__] content you know
when people say that to me oh you're
only funny because of the action i i go
like i wish it was that easy because in
my stand up i do both i open as uncle
roger and then i come as myself and do
an hour i wish the accent alone would
get laughs man because uncle roger comes
out sure the first 10 seconds they're
excited
but then you got to be funny i got to
have jokes
i could just be like
and get laughed i'll tell you this
though like the uncle roger thing was so
believable i i didn't know that that was
a character really
it took me a while the only reason why i
knew was cause i had to go back into
your stand up i was like oh wait this is
not who he is
i was like oh okay that's what i'm
saying
it just it it was the character was so
good i actually thought that uncle roger
was a real person
you know when you were like talking i
was like i could see that that's a real
person it has to be a real person
and also the number of white people who
started eating msg i'm doing so much
good for asian culture man this is a
[__] philanthropist yeah white people
tag me in their stories but look at this
on garager are you proud of me i'm like
yes i am proud of you yeah
it's [__] amazing
the hell are you talking about missing
out you know who did a video uh about
you was uh do you know you guys know
this guy named vincenzo's plate yes yes
i've collabed with him you know oh
really not in person but we did
something together oh that's dope
vincenzo's play this guy he's the most
italian [__] i've ever seen in my life
yeah i love his videos just because he's
so [__] italian and he was talking
about because you were making the
carbonara which looked [__] fire so
you actually do cook yeah yeah i'm an
okay i used to think i was a good cook
until i started doing these videos and i
be these videos if it's a dish i don't
know like fur i do research i jump on a
zoom car as a professional chef and then
after they tell me their process i'm
like oh i'm a very [__] cook
terrible well you're good we're good i'm
okay yeah yeah yeah your home cooks
yes so when you have like these
professional chefs so i saw your
carbonara that's great but he freaked
out when you put a little msg i was like
hey bro msg's fire you don't know it's
not as salty as you think it is a
compound like you carbonara is pecorino
cheese right yeah pretty sure pecorino
has msg in it the the chemical compound
you get the umami taste yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i'm just enhancing it i think
people freak out about that a lot and i
think it's just because back in the day
you know they talked about it causes
cancer or some [__] but it was like
this study that was completely fudged so
there was a lot of things back in the
day where they wouldn't give like the
the full extrapolated data and so i i'm
correct me if i'm wrong you guys can
research this for yourself this isn't a
[__] science podcast but they gave
like lab mice or whatever the control
was a certain amount of msg right but
the amount of it correlated to a human
was like us taking down a bag of msg oh
yeah so it that was a study that kind of
[__] everything up so everybody's like
don't have msg but there's natural
occurring in msg like specifically with
japanese food you use kombu yeah coco is
literally used just for the msg
and that's what make things it makes it
so fire it makes it so delicious yeah
and a lot of things in life
are bad for you they still do them i
know alcohol you know
probably get a shorter life if you ask
me in public too much
people chase you down um but
life is too short to always be healthy
man you go you gotta do it do some drugs
enjoy your do you like your life no man
like it's it's like i'm like i said like
everything has changed for you
um were you waiting for this moment
where it's like okay i'm gonna stay on
my grind and then this thing's gonna pop
off and now that has happened like how
has how has your perspective changed
well you i'm i'll i'll be like i will
stay on this grind but you never know if
things will pop off and that never
guaranteed anything in the entertainment
industry in any creative pursuit some
people work their whole lives are very
very funny but things just never popped
off for them so you just have to keep
hustling i told myself i would have
given myself to like 33 35
and if things weren't still weren't like
if i still couldn't support myself
solely through comedy now i just quit
and go back to my day job i used to be a
data scientist if i went full time
god put the north western degree
together
this podcast is brought to you by better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals maybe you realize
that your mental health needs a boost or
is just something you haven't really
focused on in your life i personally
have done online counseling and therapy
and it's been great mental health has
been a huge focus in my life especially
the past year and something that i
believe that people should tend to on a
consistent basis better help is great
because they can match you with your own
professional license therapist you can
schedule your sessions via phone
communicate and message online video
calls and you can even change your
counselors if needed if you want to give
this a try of course for my genius brain
listeners i got the hookup for you to
get 10 off your first month of
betterhelp just type in betterhelp.com
genius to get that offer today once
again that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash genius to get 10 off your first
month of better help to a better you uh
so yeah i was just hustling uh all the
time i would there was a point in my
life where i had a full-time job nine to
six ten to six and that would rush off
take a train in the uk to birmingham
somewhere hour and a half train do the
gig come back home it's like 11 30
midnight sleep repeat four or five
nights a week god damn yeah that that's
the grind man that's why i had no time
for my ex-wife they're still friends now
it's just we have a good relationship
now but when i was married to her i was
like oh yeah of course you would leave
me i wasn't around yeah you know uh but
and then you're like oh i'm uncle roger
now [__] yeah yeah bet you would have
stuck around
she was very nice so okay you know when
you when you get a divorce uh
the the partner's entitled to 50 50
split right and she didn't take anything
she was like you worked hard for this i
saw how hard you work and what's yours
it's yours what's mine is mine you know
that's amazing oh right yeah very
un-american of her she was american no
she's european okay so they europeans
divorce is a very common thing her
parents are divorced and sometimes you
do you marry someone divorce them by the
time your third marriage comes around
it's the first wife again you know
that's how casual they are
that's crazy i know right can you
imagine and then and then
her uncle who's divorced he would go to
his ex-wife's wedding
because they're still they're divorced
but they still have a good relationship
you know but in america divorce is like
you i've seen the movies it's messy as
lawyers yeah yeah yeah and stuff
i have a friend too who um
he was like traveling a lot and then he
was like when he went to europe and he
was just like going on dinner and
hooking up with people because like sex
is a lot more casual here oh in europe
yeah oh yeah it's super casual because
he's lucky to be in
he says like number one it was easier to
talk to women uh number two uh hooking
up was just kind of like we're gonna
hook up first and then we'll see if
we're compatible yeah
and his the the process was completely
reversed in how it is over here yeah i
have a joke in my in my show that i talk
about it's um
dating asia you know is is very innocent
because that's where i started before
coming to america you you meet you you
go to a restaurant you watch a movie
maybe a few months on the line you have
sex right and in in in britain the sex
just happens at the first that's the
first thing and the last thing you do
dating in in the west is holding hands
you know i've done anal with someone
before holding their hands you know so
that that is the difference there and
especially in europe uh europe more so
and uk as well
people view sex as just whatever man and
then they view it like what if we get
along really well but then the sex sucks
so let's find out the sex first let's
get to know each other afterwards that's
so funny so that is true then right yeah
it's a lot more casual out there which
is insane i [__] up i grew up in the
wrong place dude it's all right you have
your nice christian wife yeah i know is
she a good cook because she lets me see
her naked once a year dude oh wow that's
a lot that's a lot for a christian
she just shows me the collarbone yeah
and then she disappears
if it's a birthday maybe maybe if i get
lucky i have to like go look
your abroad but that's pretty [__]
dope man like yeah i don't enjoy the
single life you know so so you're single
now then yeah yeah yeah yeah when did
you get divorced uh the
final it finalized we separated in 2019
in september 2019 like uh june 2019
actually and then i was after the
separation i'm like okay i have nothing
now so let's just go full time stand up
and i went full time stand up six months
before the pandemic you know damn right
as the guy was eating the bat for the
first time
yeah what made you want to go into
stand-up i started doing it in
university and in evanston you know and
uh
yeah i studied in uh
did my bachelor's degree in uh at
northwestern so
in the u.s
that's crazy that uh it's so interesting
i guess like for me when i see people
who first of all
like stand up is
well malaysia english is the first is
the first
no i think most people speak malay there
but i grew up by bilingual yeah uh okay
trilingual actually malay mandarin
english
a lot of the malaysian friends they all
speak english they learn english there
well yeah the malaysians were here
yeah you're seeing a very biased sound
okay okay yeah okay but but but if you
go to malaysia most of us speak english
yes but now it's the first language
you understand
thailand where you're [__] yeah you
know and it's just i i love bangkok man
it's great but um
uh the the the red light district is is
something it's not crazy it's crazy yeah
you think amsterdam is bad but like
absolutely at least in amsterdam have
you been to amsterdam the red light
district there no so basically that
prostitutes just behind a glass door
and they're just showing themselves off
you can just walk in there and you know
have sex with it's very open like that
and people think that's crazy but in in
bangkok the prostitutes are there too
but there's no glass doors so you just
come and grab your dick
you know and try to drag you into the
bar with them god damn it
i feel like you know is this what women
feel when they walk they're getting cat
called oh that's because the [__]
girls are nice
the girls are men over there
they still got their habits
the man
what they call it the the ladyboys
that's the term for that yeah i don't
know if it's appropriate that's what
they call them and they're they're hard
i went to see a show
and they're beautiful beautiful women
that's why men who are always dressed
like women or
i don't know
trends what's the correct term for this
it depends on whatever the the the
social cues are over i don't think they
have social cues like that in thailand
it's just more like [__] yeah and
it's not viewed as um a negative thing
it's just a thing it just is what it is
yeah so i i know that because uh my
buddy tim we do a podcast again he was
telling me the story where him chaturang
yeah okay he's thai and then he was like
in thailand with his dad and his dad was
like you see all those hot girls he goes
yeah they're hot he goes
yay they're all men
and shocked he was like dude these were
the hottest men he's ever seen in his
life
because i think they still identify as
guys they just you know they're just
ladyboys so it's like
he was just telling me like oh why not
did you and adam's apples you know
it's just another lump to grab on dude
one two three
one at the top
he's sort of covered their face when
coming to adam's apple you know that's a
nice experience
there's this [__]
there's this one video it's it's
literally the most ridiculous video i've
ever seen uh a buddy send it to my buddy
send it to me it's like a
there's this website called e-bombs
world where they would just have like
the most lewd [__] ever but it's
literally this guy
[__] with this uh [__]
and then but you don't know it just
looks like this hot girl
and he just keeps calling her steve
like
like show me your dick steve show me
your dick it's like show me your dick
what do you mean and then
the camera pants and you just see this
[__] dong
i'm like what the [__] is going on here
i was like oh it's a lady boy from
thailand it's not fair as they're pretty
as a woman and they have a huge dick
come on man come on come on you can't
have best of both worlds you greedy [__]
i wouldn't mind being being with one but
i can't she can't be called steve you
know at least let me suspend that
disbelief you know i wonder why she
chose stephanie can we do stephanie
was like yeah show me your dick steve
i'm like steve what's the point but
stephanie is it's more palatable show me
a dick stephanie
so how long are you uh here for leaving
saturday oh [__] day after tomorrow can
you talk about what you're here for oh
yeah yeah yeah i'm here i was here to be
a special guest on hell's kitchen let's
go and uh because i reviewed gordon uh
he he did fried rice really well and
then we kind of just started i started
working with his team on some stuff
hopefully they'll hopefully you know
come to fruition but you never know like
right with development stuff um but i
got to meet the guy yesterday gordon
he's a cool guy man and then we just met
and then we bitched about jamie oliver
for 10 minutes
you know
when you told me that [__] i was like
damn because i always see like uh
[__] uh gordon ramsay throwing shade
at jamie all over all the time on videos
now he has me to do his dirty work
he's a big guy too isn't he he's big man
he's like a whole head taller than me
and he was shaking my hand like you
could feel the force of the handshake
he's so the man's face looks like a
baseball mitt dude like i can't i can't
imagine him yelling at me and me
standing my ground yeah i'm just gonna
take it yeah you you yeah don't don't
show him attitude man don't you man he's
a
a bit scary i imagine i saw him yelling
at people yesterday because that's the
whole premise of hell's kitchen right
yeah so he was yelling at people for
[__] up the dishes the pasta and
stuff so scary i think i'd cry dude i'm
like this guy is he's so cause it's not
like he's a tiny little guy with little
man syndrome he's a big [__] he's
also scottish so they're the best at
cursing people out
you know they they they grew up calling
their friends [__] you know hey what's
up what's up guys
so that's what he does and he's very
good at it and he gave me a few walks so
that's very nice of him he's he's just
one of those dudes men that i i
thoroughly enjoyed like people think i
talk [__] like that oh yeah he's gotta
talk [__]
and he makes a good living people like
him though you know that's the
difference dave people like gordon
what's wrong with you
[__] no man i have like a few people
that like me i'm like i'm doing
something wrong i like you man i like
you man you know what it is it's like
real you're real i feel like with gordon
ramsay like his skill level is such so
high here he can say whatever the [__]
he wants he's like what are you gonna
say to him though like you don't know
what you're doing you say to his [__]
empire
so he has like this position of what he
can do and i think like for me too i'm
not saying i don't know what i mean you
have an empire of seven match ups i'm
trying dude then i'm gonna start talking
[__] to gordon ramsay just so i could
meet him
but you know we were talking about this
off podcast but
like i uh i kind of went into like
traditional media for a bit and i
started coming back to youtube this year
um and i want to start creating more on
youtube again because i didn't realize
how freeing it was to be here and how
amazing it is to have a group of people
who watch and care about what you do
and i think you know perspective wise i
came into youtube thinking that it was
going to be a platform for me to leave
youtube but every time i keep coming
back here
you know seriously i've done youtube and
then i've done some traditional media
stuff and the amount one the amount of
freedom
and then two you can do a lot of
traditional media stuff and never build
that relationship you have a direct
relationship with your fans you know the
fact that you can just talk straight
down the camera that is what other
traditional media has that unless you
are like
hosting american idol or some [__] but
nobody gets to know you but also the
freedom i did a project once with uh a
big corporate comedy network and the
amount of notes that are like oh doing
this might be considered offense i had a
sketch i wanted to play buddha i
couldn't play buddha we couldn't even
use the word banana
they say oh this could be considered
derogatory to some people
but it's like most things can offend
people for reals right you can't talk
about diseases
uh we had a sketch that got cut
that's what i loved it it's called [__]
psychic so it's a psychic who just tells
your future by looking at your [__]
it's a funny idea right you know what
the feedback was like
and that feedback the studio gave us a
lot of feedback but the actors we tried
to cast they were
giving us feedback like sorry this
sketch doesn't pass the bechdel test i
don't want to play this i'm like you're
a [__] unemployed woman
that's why you're an unemployed actor
because you're seeing a sketch
which is a comedy sketch
you know bringing up terms like bechdel
test
it's like
yeah it's a [__] psychic what are you
talking about she's look at his eye
you're not getting laid anymore so it up
[__] and go traveling eat pray love
namaste you know that's the whole
premise
yeah we couldn't get that sketch off the
ground which which was a shame listen
i've i've definitely
but on youtube people would click on
that [__] oh i'm gonna make [__]
sidekick when i have them uh the time
one day that's why i've kind of like i'm
not gonna say i've given up right
because everything has this time and
place
but you know when
these shows like you know fresh off the
boat and all this sort of stuff started
coming up
i had a lot of people knock on my doors
because i always talk about my personal
life story my personal lifestyle is a
little weird but they actually don't
want your personal life story because it
doesn't fit the narrative of what they
want yeah because it's still
at the very very top is still a white
guy yeah right and so like i remember
and the sad thing is is like even
there's a a certain media company that's
all asian people and they didn't want my
story they were trying to tell me what
my story should be and i'm like hold on
a second you you're the white people
that you
talk [__] about you're doing the same
thing to me yeah and so i would i told
them so for example this is a meeting
they had and we'll say we're not name
dropping so but they uh they're like oh
what's the story that you want to do i
was like well a story that i want to do
uh for a very good single cam show
it's
it's about me growing up in a
predominantly black neighborhood and
being the only asian kid there and so
it's a story about me we've already done
that it's called rush hour yeah
listen here that's not anything new all
right jackie chan was [__] chris
tucker in that thing but
it was about it's basically about
this asian guy that's trying to
assimilate into black culture instead of
white culture right which was my story
growing up
you know and there's just a little weird
nuance of like trying to hold on to
everything that makes you proud about
being a korean american but you want to
fit into this other part that another
culture that still doesn't fit in the
narrative of what white culture is so
this is like weird nuance show and
they're like
yeah but can you do more stuff about
like you growing up like kind of like
kim's convenience where you're working
at your parents store and i'm like we're
done with this conversation yeah like i
i can't talk to you guys anymore you
know oh i i get it man like people
want to hear
what they already have in their heads
you know and that's why when i do
youtube i feel like it's such a blessing
to have a bit of a following on there
and i i want to do traditional media but
i don't think i'll ever leave youtube
you know even if i do traditional media
stuff i'll still always have a hand at
at least podcasting if not making those
uncle roger comedy review videos yeah
yeah yeah the amount of freedom is it's
amazing it feels good man and we'll make
it one day man once i get it i must get
my career more off the ground and i have
like a proper perception i'm here you're
already here dude like
no no no you've been around the block
i'm just starting out and for me now is
like establishing myself first before i
can you know set up a production team
that looks after other people you know i
feel like for you man like you like
sky's the limit just because nothing you
have
you already have a vision and a goal set
in mind right like stand-up is still a
major part of who you are and is still a
part of your goal like for me i'm kind
of scatterbrained so i just
i'm living life like a [__] [__] like
some people say scatter brain some
people say entrepreneur you know
i and i i think
going to the food vertical is something
i'm trying to do too you know because it
lends itself well i like food yeah
garage stuff you know he can help other
people sell food so hopefully you know
that can kind of just kind of follow
your food steps and stuff maybe not
matcha because i'm not the biggest fan
of
it's like a green tea that's more bitter
you know
is it very insulting now am i insulting
your whole business oh so if it's bitter
that means you have bad matcha so i i
didn't know that so until i went to [__]
in japan and then i uh went to the farm
that makes our matcha
uh
and i tried it i was like oh this isn't
bitter i'm like yeah because everybody
has something called culinary grain
matcha which is that dark green stuff
that is the worst matcha you could ever
drink and it's only supposed to be made
when you bake things you need to open
your shop in london then because i've
only had bitter matcha really and i'm
like why the [__] are people so obsessed
with this
it's like worse green tea yeah yeah yeah
so it's it's supposed to be very mild so
when you have good matcha ceremonial
macho or stuff that you're supposed to
ingest it's supposed to be a bright jade
green
and so if it's dark and brown looking
number one it's either expired or it's
culinary grade or you're having like
hojicha which is completely different
yeah yeah so it's it's that's the hard
part of having a food company that's
trying to change the perspective of what
matcha is i just changed my perspective
yeah doing good so everybody who comes
in like some people come in they're like
oh it's not strong or bitter enough i'm
like you like it that way yeah like what
are you talking about
like what do you like about that
terrible pallets
like going back to our yelp right
i will forever remember this review it
was this blue-eyed blond-haired white
girl that goes this is some of the worst
matcha i've ever had and i was like like
japanese people would never serve this
stuff it's not strong enough it's
they're they're skimping out on
everything and like i like matcha from
blah blah and she was naming like other
other businesses
that have culinary grade matcha which is
this the brown stuff and that is what
she considers high quality but she's
speaking from a place of being
uneducated trying to tell other people
who by the way
two of our partners are japanese
trying to tell us how we should eat our
food it's like the audacity yeah
how could you the confidence
i know some white people have men that
was one of the things i was shocked at
when i came to the us because you go to
uni university in the us there's a lot
of discussion based stuff right which is
very different from asia asia is wrote
learning they tell you memorize [__] you
take an exam whatever
and then people are very so confident
but they're just talking [__]
they're just saying nothing and i was
like
wow
it must be nice too and then i realized
oh it's a bigger thing people say
mansplaining whatever i think it comes
from the same core of like oh
i'm very good at this yeah yeah yeah my
opinions you know i think the cool thing
is is like
when you're when you're a comic
everything's up for grabs right you
could make fun of just about anything
even if if i'm offended by something i
still think that it's okay yeah as long
as i'm allowed to clap back and then i i
just don't like to hold on to things
that make me mad but it's not a
reflection of how everybody else is
every people tend to like to hold on
things that like eat at them constantly
so it's like drinking poison expecting
somebody else to die yeah this is how
they live their life living in your head
rent free or something let the other
person yeah yeah so i'll like i'll do
podcasts all the time where i'll say
something that i believe is true and
then the next podcast i'll correct it
and they go look at you wish-washy as
[__] it's like no i just learned things
along the way i'm becoming a better
human being yeah you know
let me correct what i say you know what
i mean like i [__] up like i had an
opinion about something and i'll change
it later on like the first time i made
that tweet to just me clicking on one of
your videos i was like
[__]
you know and then i corrected it in a
podcast yeah yeah so it's like i'm
allowed to make these changes like
yeah well
nobody's [__] perfect right i can
talk about the ideal way that i'd like
to communicate but i'll make the same
mistakes that i kind of [__] on other
people for because we tend to hate the
qualities that we hate in ourselves and
other people so we're always going to
change and evolve all the time i think
that when you leave things up in the
comedy though allow us to make mistakes
and [__] up as long as like the joke is
there i'm pretty much okay yeah give us
a safe space essentially you know we
give we give uh trans people safe spaces
with like the gender inclusive bathrooms
and stuff and i'm cool with that so i
think comics should have you know
where's our where's our bathroom yeah
where's our bathroom where we can talk
[__] about anyone yeah and not get
canceled you know yeah like and i think
it's very cool too where we're now we're
in a world where
it's weird like
they're we're accepting of certain
things but we're trying to exclude other
people now it's like we've got to kind
of let's let's paint it all with like a
similar brush dude let's all have an
understanding of each other let's allow
people to make mistake especially comics
because i i feel like comics are getting
canceled a lot now for material that
they're working up on stage i will say
this though like after going through my
last cancellation it's actually made me
realize
you can't really get cancelled you come
back the only way to get cancer is if
you kill yourself
there's no other way like if with
youtube it's like okay you cancel me now
but i can just press record and upload
another video how are you gonna stop
that unless youtube bans me okay i have
facebook instagram twitter tick tock you
know okay i think like
being
i think everybody in this creative field
should try to get cancelled once and
then you see how unscary it is and how
little of an impact it has in your
career and then you feel brave enough to
take more risks and create better art or
you just be a piece of [__] yeah you can
oh you can always go right wing and
start shading on minorities that's up to
you too
like i'm consistently canceled 24 7 all
the time and it's just like
you know the difference between me and a
lot of other people is i already just
tell people straight up i'm dumb like
i'm not i'm not a moral beacon for
anybody so if you want to cancel me for
not saying the right things you came to
the wrong [__] channel what does your
wife say about that she's like david
uh
hold it down a bit david so she said
that because he's a good like very nice
person we had a we had a very
uh deep conversation when we first
started dating it said you don't tell me
how to do my job i don't tell you how to
do your job oh okay what does she do uh
she works uh in animation so like she
worked for disney and uh all these other
like pixar and all this other stuff it
would be funny if you started telling
her how to do her job
yeah that you need more frames there for
the movement you know honey i love you
but that you know the neck you animated
it wrong you know yeah and she
understands too now it's like because
it's too hard for me to understand what
she does it's hard for her to understand
what i do i just said that at the end of
the day like i respect what you do
respect what i do um and you know in the
beginning too i would show her videos
and she wouldn't laugh and i'm like
i'm still going to post it
i'm still going to post it but her sense
of humor too is similar to mine but not
at the same time so if um because she
doesn't really curse she doesn't do it
she's the she's like i'm the antichrist
opposite
i think yeah
so we definitely have things that we
pull pull from each other right and
sometimes when she looks back and she
goes i would have never thought i would
have ended up with somebody like you
yeah like scum off the earth
like this piece of [__] her mom didn't
like me at all really because her mom is
hyper religious she's korean too right
she's great oh how do you do that the
mother-in-law thing is always i just had
to show her how much i make
the most before adpocalypse
before an apocalypse keep me quiet now
she's going to listen to his podcast
like you're poor how much money you make
you want to do the terrible
the [__] funny trick that i did was
she i could tell she didn't like me just
by body language and [__] right
and i think i was like oh i think she
thinks i'm
just a bum like i just sit at home and i
do absolutely nothing so we did a grand
opening for one of our matcha stores and
then we had a fan meet and greet and
like 500 people showed up wow and when
she showed up she couldn't get parking
there and she's like what is this i was
like they're here for me
and i think that was like
oh
david
making so much money
it's like i could talk about them now
yeah they see the the lack of parking
spaces and their minds are going yeah
he's making good money
but she definitely
it took a lot for her to warm up to me
right because at the end of the day i
think what the great thing is is about
her families i met her other family
members and they were all vouching for
me so he's a good guy like like just
don't google him just but he's a good
guy
she mentions my videos too she goes oh
you cursed a lot i was like that's how i
grew up yeah you know like i you know
she knows how i grew up it's different
it's not going to change like i i
definitely code switch around other
people's families and kids though yeah
you have to man yeah yeah i'm not going
up to other kids and being like what's
up little [__] [__] boy good morning
you know what i said about uh coast
wishing to get laid yeah that's why i
co-switch around kids you know
[Laughter]
put me on epstein island i love curse
i just meet the ladies
you know
oh man dude you're crazier than i am
i try i try
i try really hard dude david thinks he
could get cancelled watch this
[__] man hey you want to shout out
before we wrap up this podcast i mean i
could talk for hours but we're getting
hungry yeah we're going to get tacos
check out matcha place man i want to
have some good matcha oh yeah man yeah
yeah yeah
okay well um give me a follow on all the
social media you can search find me on
mr nigel ung m-r-n-i-g-e-l
i'm also doing a world stand-up tour
it's called the haya tour hell yeah baby
so uh i'll be in la san fran new york
philadelphia toronto vancouver
everywhere australia if you listen to
this over there um just search
nigel ung and on google nigel and tour
and you will find the tickets there so
you're [__] nigel i thought i was in
well ing is probably more the anglicized
pronunciation i know like there's a
writer here celeste ing yeah so she
pronounces it that way but i grew up
saying um because if you translate it
from the actual mandarin word it's a
dialect my actual work is huang
but in the dialect it's pronounced
with a tone going up okay so that's how
i pronounce it but if you call it nigel
that's fine too um
what they're saying yeah just just
google me on there hopefully see you at
a tour show
perfect well genius brains every sundays
at 12 p.m we'll see you all next time
shout outs to nigel check him out and
all this [__] as if i need to [__]
tell you
okay we'll see you all next time peace